حسب مؤسسه الاحصاء الامريكيه
10 الى 20% من المجتمع الطلابي في اي دوله
يعاني من صعوبه التعلم اذا جينا نطبق هذه
النسبه على الكويت احنا قاعد نتكلم ما بين
60 الف الى 120 الف طالب يعاني من صعوبه
التعلم واغلبهم ما نعرف عنهم معكم لجين
الوزان 17 سنه في ممرات المدارس واروقتها
بين الطلبه واولياء الامور والمعلمين
واليوم راح اغير منظركم عن التعليم
المدارس كلها متشابهه متشابهه بفكرتها
طالب يدخل جدول كتاب مدرسي يدرس باسلوبه
احيانا اذا هو مجتهد راح يدرس باكثر من
اسلوب يعطيهم ورك يعطي امتحان وخلصنا صح
هذه الطريقه اللي انا درست فيها والطريقه
اللي امي ابوي يدرسوا فيها والطريقه اللي
عيالنا الحين قاعد يدرسون فيها ما تغير
فيها شيء
المدارس والتعليم بحاجه الى غربله بحاجه
الى تغيير شامل الى اعاده هيكله انا اقول
احيانا الى نصف واعاده بناء
التعليم اليوم انا شبهه بجهاز النوكيا
واحنا الحين في زمن الايفون ما عدا
النوكيا يلبي طموح ولا يلبي الاحتياجات
واليوم انا ما راح اتكلم عن المناهج اللي
نحتاج نغيرها ما راح اتكلم عن الهدف اللي
اصلا طلع عشان التعليم النظامي اللي احنا
كلنا قاعدين نتعلم فيه اليوم تدرون ان
التعليم النظامي اللي انتم تشوفونه اليوم
المدارس والفصول بشكلها هذا بدات مع
الثوره الصناعيه كان الهدف منها انه
يخرجون عمال مصانع يتميزون بالانضباط
والانصياع
والامور هذه فحتى الهدف اصلا من التعليم
اللي احنا اليوم قاعد
نمارسها تغير هذا يعني فعلا يحتاج تغيير
طبعا التصميم المعماري للمدارس شكل الفصول
من قال الفصول اصلا لازم تكون اربع بيبان
والطالب يقعد توقيت الدراسه دخول وخروج
الطلبه الجانب الحسي تفاعلي ربط المدرسه
مع الطبيعه امور وايد وايد ودي اتكلم فيها
لكن ما هي موضوعي هذا اليوم اليوم راح
اركز على موضوع خطير جدا وغائب
غائب عن مكونات المدرسه بالشكل اللي نعرفه
اليوم
هو الصحه النفسيه
وهو دعم الطالب وتوفير العنايه النفسيه
للطالب داخل المدرسه
العلم تطور
العلم يقول لنا ان الدماغ البشري يتلقى
المعلومه بطريقه مختلفه انا اتلقاها غير
مانوره غير ما ساره غير ما كل واحد يتعلم
بطريقه مختلفه مستحيل كلنا نتعلم بنفس
الطريقه بل العلم اصلا قال لنا ان الدماغ
البشري يواجه احيانا تحديات عصبيه
تعيقه او تؤثر على طريقته في تلقي
المعلومه في تحليلها في استيعابها في
تخزينها وهذا مو مرض اكرر مره ثانيه هذا
مو مرض هذه صعوبه صعوبه التعلم صعوبه في
تلقي المعلومه من المدرس اللي اصلا تعلم
بالطريقه التقليديه اللي احنا نعرفها
واللي هو تدرب عليها
طيب مثل شنو صعوبه التعلم قاعد تقولي له
جاي صعوبات تعلم صعوبات مثل شنو مثل رقم
واحد
صعوبه القراءه
الديسكرافيا صعوبه الكتابه
الديسكال كوريا اللي هي صعوبه في
الرياضيات
الديسبراكسيا اللي هي الخلل ما بين
التواصل النظري واليدوي التاخر اللغوي
لانه مرتبط في معرفه تعابير الوجه ومعاني
الاصوات كل هذه صعوبات تعلم
وكثير منها اصلا انتشر بوقت كورونا بشكل
كبير بسبب الماسكات فالعيال ما كانوا
يشوفون تعابير الوجه ومخارج الحروف
طيب تكلمنا عن صعوبات التعلم الحيوان
المشكله بصعوبات التعلم اللوجين يعني وهو
بس مشكله اكاديميه والولد راح يفشلوا
درجاته بتكون نازله وانتهينا لا وعشان كده
انا اتكلم اليوم صعوبات التعلم تاثر على
الطالب بشيئين الجانب الاكاديمي اكيد لانه
هي راح تاثر على قدرتها على القراءه على
الكتابه على حل على عفوا الرياضيات وايضا
على قدرتها على التركيز اكيد يمرون عليكم
اطفال عندهم تركيز قليل وتشتت انتباه
الجانب الثاني والاهم اللي تاثر فيه صعوبه
التعلم اللي هو الجانب النفسي وهذا الجانب
اللي ياخذه معاه الانسان
وهو يكبر صعوبه التعلم احنا وجدنا ان اذا
ما تم اكتشافها في عمر مبكر وتقديم الدعم
اللازم لها راح تسوي مشاكل نفسيه وايد
كبيره عند الطفل وراح ياخذها معاه وهو
يكبر مثل شنو
الانعزال
يفقد علاقاته الاجتماعيه
ما يقدر يكون اصدقاء
الاحباط
القلق الغضب التوتر الاكتئاب
والتنمر تدرون ان 31% من طلبه صعوبات
التعلم يتعرضون للتنمر وما ادراك ما
التنمر
السيناريو اللي انا اشوفه دائما يتكرر
قدام عيني في المدارس لما يحس ان الطفل في
شيء اوف
ر يقولوا له ود الطفل مركز ويب لنا مركز
متخصص ويجيب لنا تقييم سلوكي نفسي عنه
يروح ولي الامر يودي الياهل المسكين مو
عارفه
المهم ولي الامر بالتقرير حق المدرسه
وهنا تبدي المشكله
لان المدرس لما يقرا هذا التقرير
ما راح يعرف يمشي على التعليمات الموجوده
فيه لان هو اصلا مو مدرب هذا المدرس شلون
يتعامل مع طفل صعوبات التعلم
ضاعت الفكره
طيب
ما يعرف يتعلم ما يعرف عفوا ما يعرف
المدرس يتعامل مع صعوبه التعلم هذه
فبالتالي شنو شنو يعني هو عاده السيناريو
شنو يصير المدرس يقول لا هذا الطفل ما
يقرا زين هو كسلان او يقول يشوف واجباتها
يشوف انه هو ما حل واجبات يدق على الام
ولدك ما حل واجبات متاخر بالدراسه فالام
على طول تخترع وبانك انا ولدي اكيد كسلان
شو تسوي الامه اول شيء دروس خصوصيه وتغرق
الطفل هذا المسكين بالدروس الخصوصيه فتعرض
هذا الطفل لضغط نفسي شديد هذا المسكين
تبي يرفع ادائه وهو ما عنده اصلا مشكله
بالاداء هو الطفل مو عارف يقرا ولا عارف
يكتب لانه عنده عسر لانه عنده مشكله في
تلقي المعلومه
لكن لان ما عندنا برامج انك تكتشف صعوبه
التعلم اللي عند هذا الجاهل فهو يمر بهذه
الدوامه كلها ويقعدها بالضغط النفسي هذا
والفشل الاكاديمي هذا اللي قاعد يصير لان
اربعين بالمئه من طلبه الصعوبات قاعد
يمرون علينا ما نكتشفهم طيب قلتي له الامر
بالمدارس يروح يجيب
من السنتر ويشوف المدرس وما يعرف يتدرب
الياهل في النهايه يضيع يروح لازم المركز
ياخذ جلسات حق عسر القراءه هي المدرسه
المدرس قاعد يعلمه بطريقه مختلفه اخر شيء
يفشل اكاديميا يغير مدرسته والنهايه
الضياع طيب شنو الحل
شنو الحل حق صعوبه التعلم
الحل في فكره
الحل في برنامج
استحدثناه وطورناه اسمه جنريشن هابي الجيل
السعيد
عباره عن برنامج مختص
للكشف المبكر عن صعوبات التعلم عند
الاطفال من عمر صغير وتقديم الدعم لهم
شلون فكره ان المدرسه
تستعين بمركز
متخصصيبه داخل المدرسه وتجيب الاختصاصيين
داخل المدرسه شنو يسوونها الاختصاصيين
يقعدون مع الطالب اللي عنده صعوبه التعلم
ويحطوله خطه متكامله لا هو بس
ويقعدون معاه داخل الصف يمه لما المدرس
يوصل المعلومه والطالب ما يعرف يتلقاها
الاخصائي راح يعلمها لهذا الطالب بالطريقه
اللي هو يفهمها ويستوعبها بل اكثر من ذلك
اذا تطلب الامر احيانا الاخصائي ياخذ
الطفل ويوديه مكان احنا نسميه ذهبي روم
عشان يعطيه تركيز اكثر بالمعلومه اللي ما
قدرت توصل له بعدين ياخذ الطالب ويرجع
الصف مره ثانيه هذا كله داخل بيئه المدرسه
خلال الوقت الدراسي بالحصص بنفس الاصدقاء
بدون ما يحتاج الطفل يغير بيته بدون ما
يحتاج يروح مسكين مركز وياخذ جلسات ويتعب
ويتاذى ابدا في نفس البيئه
دربناها وعلمناهم فالطفل الحين صار محاط
بالعنايه الكامله اللي يحتاجها عشان
يتعامل مع صعوبه التعلم لانه صعوبه التعلم
وهو شيء لازم الواحد يتعلم شلون يتكيف معه
وهذا هدف جنريشن هابي
بقول لكم قصه محمد
محمد طفل عمره اربع سنوات هو من اطفال
كورونا محمد ما في شيء بس ما يتكلم
محمد طريقته الوحيده في التواصل البكاء
امه مو عارفه شلون تتصرف معه ما يقول انا
جوعان انا عطشان انا شبعان انا باكل ما
يتكلم الولد بس يبكي والام تعبانه منهاره
مو عارفه كل من يقول لها تشخيص كلمه
يقولها وديه مكان
من مدرسه لمدرسه من احباط لاحباط من تشخيص
الى تشخيص سمعت عن برنامج
وسجل محمد بالبرنامج
ابيكم تشوفون بعد ثلاث شهور
من دخول محمد في برنامج جنريشن هابي
والجلسات اللي كان ياخذها مع اصدقائه
بالصف الطبيعي والبيئه الطبيعيه
وين وصل محمد السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته يشرفني ان القي كلمه بحق برنامج
ممكن نعتبره من افضل البرامج المتوفره
عندنا بالكويت واللي توفر التعليم
والمهارات والمنهج المناسب لاحتياجات
الطفل يشرفني ايضا اني اقول انه ولدي محمد
من اول المشاركين بهذا البرنامج لما تم
الاعلان عنه وانشائه احنا كعائلته واجهنا
صعوبه في فهم واستيعاب ما يريد هو يصالح
من رغبه معينه او شعور معين وهذا الشيء
سبب الكثير من الممكن نقول عنا نهاارات او
بكاء شديد واحباطات واضحه من طرف الطفل
فكرنا بالبدايه بان المشكله الاساسيه او
سبب الرئيسي هو عدم وجود اي خبره اجتماعيه
لدى الطفل خصوصا ان الولد في سنه 2020
فممكن نقول عنا انه هو من مواليد كورونا
فلما فتحت المدارس كنا فرحانين بانه
سيشارك اخيرا بالمدرسه ويكون عنده منفذ
يتعرف فيه على اصدقاء جدد ويكون خبرته
الاجتماعيه ويتعلم الكثير من البيئه
المدرسيه
[موسيقى]
كانت هذه اول عقبه واجهتنا لان محمد متعود
على اللغه الانجليزيه اكثر من اللغه
العربيه تم الاتصال علينا من قبل مديره
الحضانه وتم شرح موقف محمد بن حصه حيث لم
يشارك بالحصص ولم يستمع للتعليمات ويتجاهل
المدرسات واستدركنا بان محمد يحتاج لحضانه
تكون متمكنه بالتعليم والسيعاب وفهم نقاط
ضعف الطفل وحرصهم وقدرتهم على مساعده
الطفل على تطوير نفسه واتى اعلان ممكن
نعتبره هبه من رب العالمين حيث اتى بوقت
احنا كنا فيه بامس الحاجه له وهو اعلان
لبرنامج يجمع خبرات المعهد مختص وحضانه
متفتحه لفهم واحتياجات الطفل ان كان من
صعوبات تعلم او عدم انتباهه او المهارات
الاجتماعيه وهي مهارات لم يكتسبها الكثير
من الاطفال الذين انولدوا خلال جائحه
كورونا
[موسيقى]
التقييم الاول من قبل المعهد ليبين
المهارات التي يجب العمل والتركيز عليها
للطفل حتى يتم فهمها بطريقه صحيحه وذلك عن
طريق مشاركه الاخصائيه بالحصص اليوميه
للطفل كظله حتى توجه الطفل والتدرب
المدرسه خلال حصه لتوصيل المعلومه
بالطريقه المناسبه له فهذه الطريقه يستفيد
محمد من الدروس الفرديه مع الاخصائيه
بالاضافه الى استفادته من منهج المقدم الى
المدرسه بنفس الوقت وتم كسر الحواجز ولله
الحمد يوم بعد يوم والتي كانت تعيق محمد
فبالتالي اصبح يتخاطب اكثر ويعبر عن نفسه
واحاسيسه بطريقه افضل واوضح واصبح حبيبي
من الطلبه الذين يشاركون بالفصل ويساعدون
المدرسه في ترتيب الفصل واصبح يستمع
للتعليمات وارشادات المعلمه اخيرا حابه
اقول لكل ام واب بانه تدخل مبكر هو امر في
غايه الضروره لمصلحه الطفل حتى يتمكن من
التعبير عن نفسه وتنمو مهارات الاجتماعيه
بشكل افضل بطريقه صحيحه نظره المجتمع
لصعوبات التعلم خاطئه تماما ولا يوجد لها
مكان عند التفكير في مصلحه الطفل ومن راى
ب مهارات معينه ان كانت مهارات سلوكيه او
مهارات اجتماعيه او تعليميه لا يجب على
ولي الامر تركها بالاعتقاد بان يوم من
الايام سيكبر ويصبح افضل بل يتدخل ويتدارك
ويستثمر لها لاجل مصلحته ومستقبل الطفل
كلما تدخلت مبكرا كلما استفاد الطفل الحمد
لله على وجود هذا البرنامج وارجو ان يتم
الانتشار هذا النوع من التعاون بين
المعاهد المختصه والمدارس ان كانت مدارس
خاصه وحكوميه حتى ننشئ جيل واعي ومكتسب كل
المهارات المطلوبه من لا يشكر الناس لا
يشكر الله اشكر كل من اجتهد وساعه ليرى
هذا البرنامج النور فعلا احنا كاولياء
امور واطفالنا ممتنين لكم شكرا
[تصفيق]
محمد من هذه الحاله الى انه هو اشطر واحد
في الصف
وقيادي ما شاء الله عليه وعنده سوى صداقات
واهلها الحين وايد مستانسين وصار يعرف
يتواصل معاهم ويكلمهم وهذه بس بدايه
المشوار جنريشن هابي برنامج اتمنى اشوفه
في كل مدرسه في الكويت عشان يقدم الدعم
للطلاب
هذه بس المرحله الاولى قاعدين نشتغل الحين
ان احنا نطوره عشان يمس كل الجوانب اللي
تخص بشخصيه الطفل وتعليمه وخلونا نتذكر
كلنا كاولياء امور وكاهل ان الطفل المتزن
نفسيا هو طفل سعيد والطفل السعيد هو
المتعلم الناجح شكرا
[تصفيق]